[Music]
do you think Tony has an impressive view
take it look at this there's a two
astronauts performing one of the most
challenging spacewalks in NASA history
this morning there are 250 miles above
the southern tip of South America it's
the second in the series of high state
spacewalks to save a critical two
billion dollar science experiment on the
International Space Station it was not
designed to be repaired in space Janet
shamlian is at the Johnson Space Center
in Houston where the astronauts trained
Janet what are they trying to fix
Anthony it's the most expensive
experiment on the space station and it
sounds like something ripped from
science fiction the Alpha Magnetic
Spectrometer it's a complicated piece of
equipment that scientists hope one day
will answer the question where do we
come from since it was launched to the
space station in 2011 the Alpha Magnetic
Spectrometer or AMS has captured
billions of cosmic rays searching tiny
particles for clues about the origins of
the universe but it's cooling system is
failing and without a fix the experiment
will die and the first question was do
you think this is possible space station
commander Luca parmitano an Italian
engineer an American astronaut Andrew
Morgan an army doctor trained for the
complicated repair job it took four
years of planning we're going to perform
what could be considered open-heart
surgery on this amazing experiment let
me know when you're ready to retreat
last Friday the astronauts prepped their
patient par Montano removed the
experiments debris shield morgan tossed
it overboard okay the red is removed to
practice the operation NASA built a
life-size AMS mock-up out of plywood in
Houston this is where we're opening up
the rib cage engineer Justin Cassidy
helped design some of the 20-plus new
tools astronauts needed to replace the
cooling system the delicate job involves
cutting and fusing tiny four millimeter
metal tubes all while wearing bulky
pressurized gloves wearing it is is
makes everything more complicated your
dexterity becomes quite challenged
kind of like working with hockey gloves
everyone's on their a-game there's been
a lot of work practicing preparing for
this mission what if we put those tubes
together and that doesn't work that is
not a good day for us today spacewalk is
expected to last six and a half hours
and at least two more of them are
planned and while AMS has exceeded its
life expectancy NASA scientists say the
information coming from it is so
valuable it's worth it to try to extend
its life
Anthony Janet thank you it's a dangerous
job because they said there's really
sharp edges on the outside of it and you
could rip your spacesuit so they've to
be really careful and I heard no
handrails yeah I need handrails just
walking outside the building so it's
awesome to be in space and not have
handrails good job though and if you
want to watch the spacewalk for yourself
we're streaming it live on our CBS this
morning Facebook page through the
commercial break that's facebook.com
slash CBS this morning